antes reunidos en la pista de la antigua
aeropuerto ataturque de Estambul un
importante símbolo para el presidente
reyeta y everton en su carrera por la
reelección erdoan ahora quiere más que
nunca revivir la imagen del padre de la
nación
fui alcalde de Estambul ascendía el
cargo de Primer Ministro y luego la
presidencia
pero hemos pasado por estas etapas
juntos con ustedes
y ahora Estamos de nuevo en el camino
con ustedes
[Aplausos]
un camino que empezó hace 20 años cuando
se convirtió en Primer Ministro en 2003
erdoan era un símbolo de Esperanza su
partido el akp que había ganado las
elecciones parlamentarias el año
anterior prometió reactivar la economía
y luchar contra la corrupción el país
estaba sumido en una crisis financiera y
luchaba por recuperarse el gran
terremoto de Smith en 1999
durante 10 años erdoan dirigió una
política de inspiración neoliberal que
permitió el despegue el crecimiento
Turco un desarrollo económico que
aumentaría su popularidad y lo llevaría
en la presidencia de Turquía en 2014
pero el milagro solo duró un tiempo a
partir de 2018 durante su segundo
mandato presidencial reepta y everton
afrontó una sucesión de crisis
financieras y una inflación récord
los responsables son los que nos
gobiernan
ellos toman todas las decisiones
relativas a la economía y al país han
tomado malas decisiones antes era
partidario del akp pero ya no pienso
votarles
en sus inicios el akp el histórico
partidon abogaba por un isla moderado y
se declaraba proeuropeo pero con los
años las convicciones islamistas y
conservadoras de erdogan se fueron
apoderando de la Esfera pública y
rediseñaron las instituciones del país
en 2008 las élites laicas turcas
deploraron el levantamiento de la
prohibición del velo en la universidad
al considerar que representaba un
importante retroceso para la Turquía
moderna lo mismo ocurre en materia de
derechos humanos desde el fallido
intento de golpe de estado de julio de
2016 las purgas y los encarcelamientos
arbitrarios se han acelerado aún más
mientras el presidente Turco siga
haciendo todo lo posible por amordazar a
la oposición nada garantiza que sigan el
cargo el 29 de octubre para celebrar el
centenario de la República de Turquía